สวัสดีค่ะครูนิคสวัสดีครับ kore เรียม
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนวันนี้เราเจอกันวันอะไรคะครูนิ
วันนี้ครับวันนี้วันอะไรวันนี้วันพุธวัน
นี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
12 ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนตุลาคมครับ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
แล้วปีคศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2022 ครับ
ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะ
6 นาที
เป็นยังไงคะ
อเมริกามานานหรือยัง
ถ้าตอนนี้ก็ 1 ปีครึ่งแล้วครับ
บางอย่างคิดถึงบางอย่างก็ไม่คิดถึง
เดี๋ยวเล่าให้ฟังว่าทำไมทำไมก็
คือ
คิดถึงเนี่ยอย่างแรกเลยคืออาหาร
เพราะคุณนิดชอบกินแล้วที่อเมริกาเนี่ยถ้า
เราอยากกินข้าวคือมันก็จะไปร้านอาหารมัน
จะไม่มีเหมือนกับ
อย่างแรกคือมันจะไม่มีพวกของขายตามถนน
หรือ
ถ้าเราอยากจะกินอะไรเราก็ออกไปอย่างน้อย
เซเว่นมีที่ไทย 24 ชั่วโมงเปิดตลอดเวลา
ใช่รู้สึกอุ่นใจ
แต่ที่นี่มันไม่มีอะไรที่เปิดตลอดเวลาแถว
บ้านคุณนิดนะ
วันนี้ก็เลยคิดว่าน่าจะเป็นเรื่องอาหาร
ที่ทำให้คิดถึงประเทศไทยใช่ๆคือประเทศไทย
อยากกินอะไรมันหากินได้ตลอดเวลาแล้วก็
มันจะกินอะไรก็ได้ตลอดเวลาคือเราตื่นเช้า
มาสมมุติ 8 โมงเช้าตอนนี้อยู่ดีๆอยากกิน
แกงเขียวหวานแล้วก็ไปร้านข้าวราดแกงที่มี
อาหารเยอะๆแล้วก็เขาก็ตัดให้เรากินใส่จาน
ก็ได้ใช่ๆ
ตอนที่เรียนไปเวียดนามไปประมาณ 10 วัน
แล้วเรียนแบบคิดถึงอาหารไทยมาก
เรียนแบบเอออยากกินอยากกินส้มตำอยากกิน
อะไรที่มันเผ็ดๆเพราะว่าไปที่เวียดนามก็
แบบอาหารก็อร่อยนะแต่ยังอยากกินเผ็ดๆ
ใช่ก็เลยก็เลยถามครูนิดไงว่าครูนิคจะคิด
ถึงประเทศไทยไหมขนาดเรียนแบบไม่ได้อยู่
นานเป็นปีเรียนก็ยังแบบโอ้ยอยากกลับ
ประเทศไทยรู้สึกว่าไปที่ไหนมาก็กลับมา
ประเทศไทยก็รู้สึกว่าชอบรักประเทศไทยที่
สุด
ก็ของคุณนิคเนี่ยคือเรื่องอาหารต้องบอก
ก่อนว่าไม่ใช่ว่าอาหารไทยอย่างเดียวนะคือ
แค่รู้สึกว่าการหาของกินในประเทศไทยเนี่ย
มันง่ายมาก
[เพลง]
อยากกินอาหารญี่ปุ่นก็มีนะอาหารเกาหลีสี
มีหมดแล้วก็คุณนิดคิดว่าของกินในประเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยเขา
คือราคามันบางอย่างมันแพงแต่คนนี้ก็คิด
ว่ามันมันสมเหตุสมผลก็คือราคาเท่านี้กับ
ของที่เราได้มันก็โอเคก็คุ้ม
แต่ที่นี่บางครั้งเรารู้สึกว่ามันแพงเกิน
ไปหรือถ้าเราสมมุติตอนเช้าเราอยากกินอ่ะ
ถ้าไม่ได้พูดว่าเป็นอาหารไทยนะครับยกตัว
อย่างอื่นมาตอนเช้า 7 โมงเช้ามีร้านอาหาร
เช้าแต่อยากกินเหมือนอยากกินก๋วยเตี๋ยว
อ่ะอยากกินเหมือนราเมนอย่างนี้อาหาร
ญี่ปุ่นได้ไหมเยอะ
ใช่ไม่มีเพราะว่าถ้าเป็นพวกอาหารญี่ปุ่น
หรืออาหารที่มันดูเยอะดูหนังก็จะต้องรอ
มื้อเที่ยงหรือไม่
โดยเฉพาะมื้อเช้าเขาก็มีแต่ก็จะเป็นอาหาร
เช้าที่เป็นเหมือนกับแซนวิชหรือพวก
โยเกิร์ตหรือที่เป็นคนไทยที่เรียกว่าเป็น
อเมริกัน Breakfast มันก็มีก็คือค่อยเป็น
แบบไข่
เบคอนแฮมหรือมันฝรั่งใช่มันก็จะคนไทยทั่ว
ไปคิดว่ากินแล้วก็จะหิวข้าวอีกไม่อิ่ม
แบบนั้นมันก็เลยรู้สึกว่า
เป็นเรื่องแรกเป็นอย่างแรกที่คิดถึง
ประเทศไทยคือของกิน
แล้วแบบยังคิดว่าอย่างที่ 2 ก็คือเรื่อง
ความเป็นมิตรความเป็นเพื่อนของคนไทย
คือคนที่อยู่บ้านบ้านข้างๆรู้จักเตรียม
ทั้งหมด
แล้วก็มีอะไรเขาก็แบบเป็นยังไงเรียนเป็น
ยังไงบ้างจะไปไหน
อันนี้คนไทยส่วนตัวนะเรียมชอบแต่ไม่รู้นะ
อีกหลายๆคนอาจจะบอกว่าไม่ชอบ
แล้วคุณนิดในส่วนคุณนิดเป็นยังไง
สำหรับครูนิคเนี่ยไม่ชอบคือจะบอกว่าไม่
ชอบก็ไม่ใช่เพราะว่าคือที่อเมริกาเนี่ย
ที่คุณนิอยู่เนี่ยคนแถวบ้านคุณนี้เขาก็
เป็นมิตรนะก็เออข้างนอกก็ทักทายคุยกัน
หรือบางทีเนี่ยขับรถในหมู่บ้านแค่ขับรถ
ผ่านเจอคนในหมู่บ้านเนี่ยก็ต้องเหมือนกับ
ทักทายนะแต่ไม่ได้ทักทายที่แบบต้องจอดรถ
แล้วคุยคือก็ประมาณเหมือนกับว่าโบกมือใช่
เราต้องทำอย่างนี้คือ
คือก็เป็นมิตรกันที่ว่าทุกคนทำ
เหมือนกับขับรถผ่านมีคนเดินมาเขาก็ยกมือ
ให้หรือคนที่ขับรถผ่านสวนกันมาก็ยกมือให้
ก็จะเป็นเฉพาะคนในหมู่บ้านใช่เพราะเขาถือ
ว่าก็อยู่ใกล้ๆกันอยู่ในหมู่บ้านเดียวกัน
[เพลง]
ใช่ก็โอเคสำหรับตรงนั้นคุณนึกเขาคิดว่า
โอเค
ที่บอกว่าคุณนิคไม่ชอบที่ไทยเพราะว่าแถว
บ้านคุณนิดเนี่ยก็มีเหมือนกับคุณป้าคุณ
ลุงทักทายธรรมดาแต่มันก็จะมีบางบ้านที่
มากเกินไป
อยากรู้ถามเราทุกอย่างตอนนี้แต่งงานหรือ
ยัง
คู่นี้ก็
อยู่บ้านนี่แหละไม่ได้ออกไปไหนแต่ว่าก็
คือออกไปซื้อของกินหรือไป
ไปหาเพื่อนก็จะเป็นว่าเขาก็จะชอบนั่งหน้า
บ้านคุณป้าคนนี้คุณนิดก็อ่ะรอบแรกออกไป
ซื้อของกินตอนเช้าเพราะอ้าวไปทำอะไรผมไป
หาของกินโอเคกลับมาแล้วก็
ต่อไปก็ออกไปซื้อของ Super
อ้าวไปทำอะไรอีก
คือออกจากบ้าน 3 ครั้งถาม 3 ครั้งมันเป็น
แบบเหมือนกันทักทายถ้าชาวต่างชาติก็แบบ
Hello  Hello อะไรแบบนี้ใช่ไหมแต่คนไทย
ก็จะใช้คำถามเป็นการแบบทักทายไปไหนจะไป
ไหนถามครูนิดอยู่ 3 รอบ
อีกครั้งนะคุณนึกออกไปหาเพื่อนเขาบอกออก
ไปข้างนอกอีกแล้วหรอ
เห็นออกไปตั้ง 3 วันแล้วนะคนอื่นพวกคิด
แล้ว
ทำไมล่ะมันเป็นคำทักทายสำหรับเด็กนะ
ว่าเรียมก็ถามนะถามคนอื่นว่าจะไปไหนแล้ว
มีครั้งนึงอ่ะที่ขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์นะแล้ว
อีกคนนึงก็ขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์มาอีกด้าน
หนึ่งแล้วทั้งสองคนเนี่ยก็ถามจะไปไหนแล้ว
ก็ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์ฟรี
ก็คือไม่ได้ตอบไม่มีใครตอบมีแต่คนถามว่า
จะไปไหน
เหมือนทักทายอ่ะ Hello
รู้สึกว่าเออแถวบ้านคุณนิคเนี่ยเขาคือบาง
ทีใช่เป็นการทักทายแต่แค่ว่าคำถามบาง
คำถามบางอันเนี่ยเรารู้สึกว่า
จะรู้ไปทำไมบางทีมันเป็นคำถามเราก็เลยรู้
สึกว่าเราต้องตอบบางอย่างไป
ใช่ไหม
แล้วถ้าแล้วถ้าเป็นเรื่องที่ 3 นะเรื่อง
ที่แบบประเทศไทยสบายๆ
อันนี้
อันนี้คุณมีอาจจะ
สบายๆเนี่ย
สำหรับคนสำหรับประเทศไทยคุณนิจะมองเรื่อง
ของการ
ไม่ตรงเวลาซึ่งไม่ชอบอันนี้อันนี้แค่คุณ
นิดคิดว่าคนไทยเหมือนจะสบายๆมากเกินไป
แล้ว
บางทีเรื่องเวลาเนี่ยคนไทยก็บอกไม่เป็นไร
5 นาที 10 นาทีสายไม่เป็นไรปล่อยไป
ถ้ารู้สึกว่าสำหรับคนที่รอเนี่ยเขาอาจจะ
ไม่โอเค
[เพลง]
ใช่ๆเราอาจจะสบายๆกับหลายๆเรื่องเราก็รวม
ทั้งเวลาด้วย
สำหรับสำหรับคนที่มาจากประเทศอื่นพอมา
อยู่ประเทศไทยแล้วเจอคนไทยเป็นแบบนี้เขา
ก็เลยรู้สึกอ๋อไม่โอเคทำไมคนไทยเป็นแบบ
นี้
คือใช่คนนี้ก็เห็นด้วยตรงนั้นแต่สำหรับ
คุณนิคเนี่ยคือถ้าบอกล่วงหน้าว่าเออพอดี
รถติดอาจจะเลท 10  15 นาทีถ้าบอกแบบ
กระทันหันคนนี้ก็ไม่เป็นไรสมมุติว่านัด 8
โมงเช้าแล้ว 7 โมง
ว่ารถติดอีกประมาณ 10-15 นาทีถึงนะแบบ
นั้นน่ะ
รู้ว่าอ๋อมาสายเพราะอะไรแต่ถ้าบอกเงียบไป
เลยเงียบเลยแล้วมาโชว์ตัวว่าตอนแบบครึ่ง
ชั่วโมงแล้วอ่ะโทษทีมาบอกทีหลังแบบนั้น
น่ะคุณนิจะไม่โอเคอ๋อไปทำอะไรมาแบบนี้
[เพลง]
เอาเวลาที่รอเนี่ยไปทำอย่างอื่นดีกว่า
หรือถ้าบอกล่วงหน้าว่าจะสายประมาณนี้คุณ
ก็จะได้เตรียมว่าโอเคอีกกี่นาทีจะมาแล้ว
ทำอะไรอย่างอื่นได้ใช่เราจะได้เอาเวลาไป
ทำอย่างอื่น
ใช่
แล้วถ้าเกิดเป็นเรื่องที่ 4 เรื่อง
สถานที่ท่องเที่ยว
ไทยมีแบบภูเขามีทะเล
มีอะไรอีกอ่ะมี
แล้วก็
เรียนคิดว่าอาจจะเป็นข้อดีก็ได้นะที่แบบ
ไม่ได้มีหิมะ
[เพลง]
มันหนีไม่ได้แต่คนนี้ก็มีเหตุผลว่าที่ไม่
ชอบเดินป่าเดินเขาในประเทศไทยเนี่ยเพราะ
ว่าประเทศไทยอากาศมันร้อนชื้นแล้วในป่าใน
เขาเนี่ยบางทีเหมือนมันมีพวกคือคุณนี่ก็
จะไม่ชอบงู
พวกงูหรือพวกแมลงปลิงอะไรพวกนี้ใช่แล้ว
ดูดเลือดใช่มันก็เลยรู้สึกว่ามันไม่ปลอด
ภัย
แต่ก็สนุกนะเรียมเคยแบบโดนทากมาเกาะที่
เท้าเห็นแล้วก็กรี๊ดสิคะ
ไม่ทำอะไรเพื่อนเอามือดีดออกให้
[เพลง]
อย่างเดียว
ประเทศไทยอย่างนี้คุณนี้ก็จะไม่เดินเขาคน
นี้จะไม่เดินป่าพอคุณกลัวว่ามันมันรู้สึก
ว่าตัวเองไม่ปลอดภัย
[เพลง]
แต่มันก็แบบสถานที่สวยอ่ะเนอะ
แล้วก็
อีกอย่างหนึ่งยังคิดว่าข้อดีของประเทศไทย
ก็คือเรื่องของอาหารแล้วมันรวมถึงผักกับ
ผลไม้ด้วยไหม
ใช่เพราะว่ามันหาได้ไม่ยากแล้วก็ราคาถูก
ราคาถูกแล้วก็มีเยอะผลไม้ก็คือแบบโอ้โห
กินแบบกินเท่าไหร่ก็ได้
ใช่แล้วมันหาได้ง่ายแล้วของของเกือบทุก
อย่างมันมาจากในประเทศ
ใช่ๆ
แล้วบ้านแต่ละคนก็มีต้นไม้ที่สามารถแบบ
เก็บผลไม้กินได้
แซ่บบางคนนะถ้าเกิดในเมืองจริงๆก็ไม่มี
ก็จริงๆใช้นั้นในมือจริงๆมันก็ไม่มีเพราะ
ว่ามันไม่มีที่แต่บางคนเขาก็จะเรียกว่า
ยังไงดีเป็นเหมือน
ผักสวนครัวที่ปลูกตรงระเบียง
อยู่ตามคอนโดอะไรพวกนี้อ๋อใช่เรียนว่ามัน
อาจจะเป็นแบบปกติของคนไทยที่แบบอยู่
ประเทศไทยอากาศเรามันดีแล้วก็ปลูกผักปลูก
ต้นไม้ได้โอเคแล้วพอไปอยู่ต่างประเทศ
เรียนเห็นหลายคนนะที่แบบพยายามปลูกต้นไม้
ปลูกผัก
เพราะเราเคยทำแบบนั้น
ที่เมืองที่คุณนิดอยู่เนี่ยผัก
เกินครึ่งมาจากต่างประเทศ
ใช่อ๋อแสดงว่าเขาไม่ปลูกเองที่นั่นเลยเขา
เขาก็มีปลูกแต่ว่าอาจจะเป็นเพราะ
เอามาจากต่างประเทศมันถูกกว่า
แค่นั้นเองใช่เพราะส่วนใหญ่ที่เอามาจาก
ต่างประเทศก็จะเป็นเหมือนอย่างเม็กซิโก
หรืออเมริกาตอนใต้แบบนั้นใช่
มันก็จะถูก
นี่ล่ะค่ะคือสิ่งที่เราพูดถึงวันนี้ก็
ความจริงมันมีทั้งแบบสิ่งที่ชอบแล้วก็
สิ่งที่ไม่ชอบมันก็ไม่ได้มีมันก็ไม่ได้มี
ชอบอย่างเดียวไม่ชอบอย่างเดียว
แล้วแต่คนด้วยใช่
สำหรับคุณนิคเนี่ยบางอย่างที่คุณบิ๊กไม่
ชอบมันก็เป็นล้อเหมือนกับ
จะเรียกว่ายังไงดีมันกินแค่ความคิดเห็น
ของคุณนิคหรืออย่างที่บอกว่าความเป็นมิตร
ของคนไทยคือส่วนตัวคุณนิดแค่ไม่ชอบที่คน
ถามเดิมๆหลายครั้งในวันเดียว
แต่อย่างครูเรียนก็อาจจะบอกว่าเออก็เป็น
การแสดงเหมือนกับการทักทายเป็น
ใช่แบบนั้นแหละเราก็เลยแบบโอเคความจริง
แล้วสรุปแล้วประเทศไทยน่าอยู่ไหม
สำหรับคนนี้คู่นี้คิดว่าน่าอยู่ไม่ได้
เปรียบเทียบกับใครนะไม่ได้เปรียบเทียบกับ
ใคร
แต่ถ้าประเทศไทยอากาศเย็นกว่านี้นิดนึง
เนี่ยก็โอเค
คิดเหมือนกันเลย
ชอบที่สุด
โอเควันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วหรือเปล่าเวลาหมด
แล้ว
[เพลง]
เป็นกังวลกับเรื่องเวลาเพราะเรียมจำไม่
ได้ลืมอ๋อโอเคไม่เป็นไรก็คิดว่าตอบนี่
แหละเวลาหมดพอดี
ถ้าเกิดนักเรียนนะคะชอบหรือไม่ชอบอะไร
ประเทศไทยลองพิมพ์มาในคอมเมนต์นะคะเราก็
จะได้รู้ว่าประเทศไทยมีอะไรอีกทำไมถึงชอบ
ประเทศไทยทำไมถึงไม่ชอบประเทศไทยเรียมอาจ
จะไม่เคยคิดเราสองคนเป็นคนไทยอาจจะไม่เคย
รู้มาก่อนก็ได้ลองพิมพ์มาให้เราดูนะคะ
สำหรับวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะครูนี้
ไว้คุยกันใหม่ในครั้งต่อไปได้เลยค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
บ๊ายบาย